when it's come to arrive people from
outside the first image they get war
bloodshed kidnapping suicide bomb all
this violence we get through the media
then the reality is not like that the
beautiful tigress is as breathtaking
they remind you the Garden of Eden my
name is Nabil Musa and I am a warrior
keeper water keeper is the voice for
rivers our mission is keeping our
waterways swayable fishable drinkable I
am the first water keeper in the Middle
East I spent most of my childhood ride
by the river catching fish playing with
frogs and that chasey dragonfly I have
some beautiful memories and I want to
bring them back the problems in an
appetite was River dams urban waste
gravel mine oil refinery and oil wells
garbage from picnickers my current
mission is educating people average
raising awareness and water quality
monitoring when the water gets polluted
find out how did that happen where's the
polluter I made a lot of people's what
I'm paddling some people they are
positive some people they are negative
they tell me you are trying to you know
stop all this pollution we've been
having them for for years and years but
our rivers are our lifeblood and if we
don't protect them our life is not going
to be safe I want to raise awareness and
tell next generation action need to be
taken I want two people to go to nature
more appreciate the water more and to
protect it
I have a right to protect this water is
my water is everybody's worth so I am
hopeful I am hopeful about the future of
Iraq and Kurdistan yes we won't get
you